- They say never become too
good at something you hate
or they will make you do it
for the rest of your life.
You ever wonder why you're
feeling negative or angry?
It's because your input
determines your output.
The garbage that you
listen to on the radio,
the trash you see on TV,
The bullshh that you hear from the people
that you hang out with.
It rubs off on you.
Hello Believe Nation, I'm Evan Carmichael
and my one word is believe and I believe
that entrepreneurs are going to solve
all of the world's major problems,
so to help you on your journey today
we're going to learn
from artist, poet, rapper
and entrepreneur Prince EA and my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd to know which one
you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're listening
if something really resonates with you,
if there's a message that
really holds true to you,
please leave it down in the comments below
and put it in quotes so that
other people can be inpsired
and when you write it down, it's much more
likely to stick with yourself as well.
Enjoy.
(swooshing)
(grand music)
- Hey, yo, my whole life
people have been telling
me to be realistic.
Is that a real job?
Are you being realistic?
Listen, realists don't
start computer companies.
Realists don't fight for
equal rights in a town
where discrimination is the norm.
Realists don't get cut
from their high school
varsity team and go on to become the best
basketball player in the world, ever.
Realists don't do that.
Crazy do it.
And you got to be a
little crazy if you want
to be successful, so don't ever tell me
to be realistic.
I refuse to accept the
reality I was given.
I'd much rather create my own.
Now a lot of you guys may not know,
but I'm a naturally shy person.
I know right, me?
Yep, been that way ever since I was a kid.
I get anxiety, I'm nervous to go
and introduce myself to people,
especially, you know, sometimes I talk
to beautiful women, yep.
I'm very shy.
I was scared to raise my hand in class.
Basically just fearful
of the things that I knew
that I should do.
Ever since childhood and it
still affects me to this day,
so I wish I would have
learned this trick back then
because I would have been more courageous,
more confident, I would
have done more things,
tried more things, said more
things that were on my heart.
But here's what you do.
Enough talking.
When you get that feeling
that you want to do something
like talk to someone you're interested in
or raise your hand, ask a
question or ask for a raise,
the longer you wait after
you get that initial
feeling, the more likely
it is that you won't
do that thing that you really want to do.
Why?
Because your mind starts to overthink,
make excuses after excuses.
Oh, what if I look stupid?
What if I get rejected?
But here's the hack.
Here's the trick.
Are you ready for it?
It's real quick, real easy and it works.
Once you know what you want
to do, count down from five.
Five, four, three, two, one.
And then go and do that
thing that you want to do.
Like a rocket ship, count
down and then blast off.
Sounds like the silliest
thing ever, but it works.
It works based on the
science of meta-cognition
and study after study have
shown it's effectiveness.
See, it quiets the negativity
bias that we have in us,
the stinking thinking,
the blah, blah, the worry.
See, worry is a misuse of the imagination.
It does nothing but drain
us of our will power,
but when you focus on the countdown,
you interrupt the worry,
the doubts and then
you can go and do what it
is that you want to do.
That's it.
See, you're just tricking your mind
and see this is such a
great tool to help you
take control of your life and start living
more authentically.
Use this for things like
waking up in the morning,
eating healthier, going to the gym,
whatever positive change
that you want to make
in your life.
This will give you the
courage to finally become
the truest version of yourself.
How much longer are you going
to say one day I'm going to,
just count and do it.
Now I didn't invent this,
this comes from the amazing
Mel Robbins, she has a great book called
The Five Second Rule.
I just finished it on Audible.
Amazing.
So check it out.
Check it out, try it guys,
let me know what happens,
what you think and who
knows, maybe you can change
your life in just five seconds.
Go.
So, you failed your final exam,
you didn't get the job that you wanted
and your relationship ended painfully.
Congratulations.
Now before you click off of this video,
I want to tell you that I myself have
been afraid of failure for
practically all my life
until I learned the truth.
And the truth is is failure is
one of our greatest friends.
I mean, success is cool,
but it naturally builds
the ego, arrogance pride
and greed, but failure,
see failure especially.
See failure naturally builds
humility, self-examination
and self-realization.
I mean failure can
bring you closer to God.
Because failure teaches us so many things
about ourselves, but only if we are quiet
enough to listen, so don't
get angry because you fail
because your anger is blocking the lesson.
See failure equals new
possibilities in life
that you didn't expect and
in life you can't expect
anything to go your way.
All you can do was put your all into what
you're doing and let go.
Sometimes you win and sometimes you learn.
I mean, there are so many
stories of successful people
failing over and over again.
I think the moral is if you're
aren't afraid of failure,
and you learn from your
failures, you can literally
fail your way to success
because a wise man once said,
even a broken clock is right twice a day.
If you guy me a gift,
right, like this one.
It's a bomb in here and
you trying to play me
and I don't take the gift.
You trying to give it
to me, I don't take it.
Who does it blow up on?
You, right?
It's the same thing
with hating on somebody.
If you're hating on me, giving
me this negative energy,
and I don't get assaulted,
it blows up on you.
You feel the pain, not me.
These videos are for haters.
Haters are not a problem.
Our reaction to the haters is the problem.
Haters aren't going
away, they're everywhere.
You can go online and find
videos of babies laughing.
Thousands of dislikes.
I mean who does that?
Only a hater.
We got to stop reacting
and taking in this gift
that they give us that makes us blow up.
And the best body armor
to protect yourself
from a hater is compassion.
If you fully put yourselves
into the shoes of a hater,
how can you hate a hater?
They aren't even haters anymore
if you put yourself into their shoes.
They're just sad people.
You realize that nobody
psychologically happy or healthy
could ever hate on
someone and I'll prove it.
I have hated on people before
and I'm sure you have, too.
We all have moments of
jealousy, envy, low self-esteem,
taking our insecurities
out on somebody else.
It's human, but go back to how
you felt when you did that.
You were unhappy.
So when somebody's hating on you,
that's where it's coming from.
Only deep internal pain
could ever make somebody lash
out and do something hateful.
These are hurt people and hurt people
want to hurt people.
And I know it's not easy
to not take this gift.
I mean it's wrapped up so nicely.
You want to debate and be defensive,
but you got to remember,
there's a bomb in here.
Don't do it.
A lot of people ask me how do I know what
my true purpose is.
The answer is the difference between a
career and a calling.
It's the difference between
satisfaction and fulfillment.
It is the difference between an interest
and a passion.
What is the difference between
an interest and a passion?
So many people are interested in this,
interested in that, but see
when you go to marry somebody,
you don't get down on
one knee and say, baby,
will you marry me?
I am interested in you.
No, you don't do that unless
you want to get smacked
in the face and then left.
You got to say, baby, I
am passionate about you.
You complete me, I cannot
truly live this life
without you, without us together.
That's operating from the heart
and if you don't operate from the heart,
I can guarantee you will live a life
climbing a ladder and
if you get to the top,
you will realize that it was laying
against the wrong wall.
They say never become too
good at something you hate
or they will make you do it
for the rest of your life.
So, look, ask yourself
these three questions.
What are your natural talents?
What is something you enjoy doing?
What is something that
you can't shut up about?
You got to read, write and talk about it.
That's how you get closer
and closer to your mission
or purpose in life.
Still confused?
Okay, so I believe that
the best teacher of how
to live life is death.
Legend has it that when
we are on our death beds,
we will be visited by ghosts.
These are the ghosts of our ideas, dreams,
abilities, talents, given to us by life
and if we never acted on that idea,
never pursued that dream,
never worked on those
skills, used our voice
or wrote that book, then
those ghosts will say
we came to you and only you
could have given us life,
but now we must die with you forever.
So ask yourself this question my friends.
Engage this start experiment.
If you had one year to
live, 365 days, and whatever
you chose to do, you were
guaranteed to succeed at,
what would you do?
Chances are that is what you
should be doing right now.
When you're on an
airplane before take off,
the flight attendant always says
in the event of an
emergency, an oxygen mask
will automatically appear in front of you.
If you are traveling
with a child or someone
who requires assistant,
secure your mask on first
and then assist the other person.
See life if just like this.
Before you go and try
to help somebody else,
you got to first help yourself.
You got to secure yourself.
Some people may call it
selfish, but if you panting
and hyperventilating in
life and you're trying
to go and help somebody
else, I don't care how
good your intentions,
chances are you're both
not going to make it.
See there's a reason they
say secure your mask first
before helping even children.
That's how important it is for you to be
stable first, because once you're stable,
then you can help the child,
you can help the old lady,
the old man, the teenager.
What I'm trying to say is that in life,
to be the most help to
others, you got to take
the time to secure your own mask,
to secure yourself financially,
mentally physically
and most importantly spiritually.
That means you got to
leave friends, family,
turn off the game, the
awards shows and just
be with yourself.
Because see, in the operating room,
ain't no visitors allowed.
No guests, no friends, no family?
Why?
Because the patient is
undergoing a transformation.
Well, in that same way,
you must get by yourself
if you want to transform
into your best version,
but let me finish with this.
After you have your mask properly secured
and you're able to breathe,
it becomes your obligation,
your duty to help others
secure their mask,
so ain't nothing wrong with being selfish
in the beginning, but
make sure the end game
is to be selfless,
because to be the only one
breathing on a plane while
everybody else is unconscious,
will surely put you on a crash course
for loneliness and disaster.
Every day we allow and
even encourage people
to dump garbage into our
minds and into our lives.
See, contrary to popular
belief, you don't just
consume nutrients through
food by way of your mouth.
You also consume through your
eyes and through your ears.
You ever wonder why you're
feeling negative or angry?
It's because your input
determines your output,
the garbage that you
listen to on the radio,
the trash you see on TV,
the bullshh that you hear
from the people that you hang out with.
It rubs off on you.
Everybody talks about
GMO, stay away from GMOs.
Well stay away from the
human GMOs, the greedy,
the miserable, the obnoxious.
These people are toxic.
They drain you, they complain, they remind
you of your mistakes.
They tear you down, the
gossip, they aren't there
for you when you need them
and some of these people
are even in your family.
But these aren't necessarily evil people,
they're just trapped
in a cycle themselves,
but that's their problem, not yours.
You can't fix them.
You have fix yourself and
become an example for them.
So politely just give yourself some space
from these people or else
you're going to end up
just like them.
You keep hanging out with losers,
you're going to wind up picking up
the qualities of a loser.
Hang out with people that encourage you
and empower you to become
the best version of yourself.
You deserve that.
You deserve to be happy.
You deserve to be you.
So figure out what you want out of life.
Because you're going
to be the only with you
for the rest of it.
Life is short.
And as a wise woman once said,
fake friends, negative friends,
ain't nobody got time for that.
I read a study yesterday.
It said that last year,
more than half of us
actually chose not take our full vacations
from our jobs.
Question?
Don't you think it's
crazy that so many of us
go into work even when we
don't need to be there?
Times we could be on
the beach buried in sand
or traveling the earth.
We spend it in the office
traveling from desk to desk,
buried in paperwork.
See, in this chaotic world,
everything goes so fast.
We're so busy it seems like everyone's
middle name is multitask.
Now before you go act
all holier than thou,
how many extra tabs do you have open
on your computer right now?
See we all need time to
get away from the race
for our family, friends, for
the sake of our mental state.
Time to rewind, recharge and reconnect.
Now reporting to the office on emails
that should be on redirect.
Because life ladies, and
gentleman is all about moments.
No one in history has ever
been able to hold on to one,
not a single soul.
And you never get them back, see?
There one goes.
No do overs, no rewind,
no DVD routing you to
skip to a previous scene.
Ask yourself how many
trips did you almost take?
How many sites have you almost seen?
How many moments have
you lost thinking about
the next one, thinking
that once you get this
or get that, maybe that
will be the best one.
Life has taught me that all
we will ever have is now.
But let me be perfectly clear.
I'm not saying to quit your job,
even though I know you
deserve a six-month vacation
twice a year, but how about
small steps, short trips
with long dances, no distractions.
Spend time with family
instead of co-workers,
meditation instead of aggravation,
replace our screensavers with sunrises,
Palm Pilots with palm
trees, jammed copy machines
with, man I really hate
jammed copy machines.
The most precious thing we
have in life are moments.
Let's make the most of
them before they disappear.
Let's see the world while we still can
and cherish those while we're still here.
Because when our lives are almost over,
it won't matter how much money we made
or hours we worked or times
we got employee of the month.
What we will look back on are the memories
we made, the hours we
spent with those we loved
and were we father of the
mother, mother of the year,
friend of a lifetime.
Holidays should be a time where we go away
and come together.
From now on, let's take our whole vacation
and be fully present, creating memories
that will last forever.
(gentle music)
One of my favorite stories is about a man.
Hey, I don't care who you are, what race,
what age, what gender, I don't
care about any of that stuff,
but what I do know is
that you have a dream
inside of you and that dream you have kept
hidden from the world.
You've made excuses for it.
You've delayed it.
You've listened to people telling you
to be realistic, but
deep down in your heart
you know that you're not
living to your potential
and life is now something
you're just getting on with.
I want to lay some
reality on you real quick.
Where is the wealthiest
place in the world?
Do you know?
It's not China, it's not Dubai.
It's the graveyard.
Because in the graveyard, you will find
inventions never invented,
business never erected,
songs never sung, books never written,
ideas never nurtured,
people never realized
because they were scared to take a risk,
scared like you.
But you want to know something else?
You're not in the graveyard yet.
We get one life, right?
And every passing moment we
will never gat back again.
You will never start this video
with the same perspective you
had when you clicked play.
You will never brush
your teeth the same way
twice in your life.
Ain't no rewind button on life.
I will never get that
breath back every again.
See, this present moment is so precious.
We have to be here, we have to be in it
and make the most of it.
We have to live our dreams
now because they are possible.
6,000 years ago man created the wheel.
On 6,000 years ago the first
written language was created.
That's it.
And if I may remind you, the airplane
is only a little over a hundred years old.
There was no internet 50
years ago, no cell phones,
so don't sit here and
tell me that everything
that can be done has been done
when we haven't been here for very long.
There are dreams, there are
ideas and accomplishments
that are waiting to be discovered,
that are waiting for you.
Helen Keller was once asked
what on earth would be
worse than being born blind?
She said it would be so much worse
to be born with sight, but no vision.
Why can't we have cures for
every disease known to man?
Why can't we have clean
water, food, education
for every person on this planet?
Why can't we have peace on this planet?
Why do we have to die to go to Heaven.
The earth is already in space.
We can Heaven right here, right now
with just a shift in this.
Why not?
Because somebody said it's
impossible, it can't be done?
I'll tell you this,
there's never been a statue
erected for a critic.
Everybody tell you how to do it,
they never did it.
Moral of the story is do you, be you
and be here now.
Your dreams are, stop obsessing
over these celebrities,
Kim Kardashian, live your life.
Step into your greatness.
They say the average person dies at 25,
but is buried at 75.
You know what that means?
I'll let you figure it out.
Don't let this negative world get to you.
Don't let it win.
Do not go where the path may lead,
but go where there is no
path and leave a trail.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Marcus Mococolla asked me to.
If there's someone you'd like to profile
in the next Top Ten, check out the link
in the description and
go and cast your vote.
I'd also love to know what
was your favorite message
from this video, what did
you learn from this video
that you're going to immediately apply
somehow in your life or in your business.
Please leave it down in the comment below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to Brandon from One Percent Better.
Brandon, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book Your One Word,
doing a review on the YouTube channel
and posting it to Twitter as well.
I really, really, really
appreciate the support man
and I'm glad you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)
- There was a study done
on 300 world leaders,
everybody from Martin Luther King
to Gandhi, to Helen Keller, you name it.
You know what they found
they had in common?
75% of them were either raised in poverty,
had been abused as children or had some
serious physical impairment.
See these individuals knew.
They became great because
they knew that life isn't
about what happens to you.
It's about how you handle
what happens to you,
it's about how you handle
what happens to you
and you can either break
down or break records.
Your choice.
So your mind is out of control, huh?
You want to control the mind.
Well, guess what?
You can't do it.
Nobody can do it.
Trying to control the mind is like
trying to flatten out water.
You just make more waves
because that's the nature
of the ocean.
It has waves, it has crashing.
You don't say there should
be waves in the ocan.
Well, the natural state of the mind
is full of thought, mental
noise and once you accept that,
the easier it will be to go beyond it,
because you are not the mind.
You have a mind, but the problem is
you have been identifying with the mind,
with your thoughts for your entire life.
If you were the ocean, why
would you identify as a wave?
It's just a wave.
Well, you are that
which observes thoughts.
Stop identifying as thoughts.
It's just a thought and what
is every thought made out of?
Nothing.
You bring it to life with
the attention you give it.
See, every single day we
have 50 to 70,000 thoughts,
but the ones that stress us are the ones
that we keep putting our attention on,
but these thoughts don't
have any more strength
than any other.
Stressful thoughts come
like a knock on the door
and you keep letting them in.
Or you say no, no, no, I
don't want you to come in,
no, no, no, stay out and that makes them
knock even louder.
So both aversion and attraction feed
and multiply thoughts.
The secret is just don't mind the mind.
Know that this is the
natural state of the mind.
Don't feed it.
You do that by not trying to control,
just hold your ground and
the thoughts will go away.
This is the law of the universe.
Everything passes.
Just stay as the observer of thought.
Don't touch them, don't
resist the thought,
label it, or create a whole
story around the thought.
Just stay as the pure awareness.
This is a much higher place,
your true place in silence.
So yeah, thoughts will
arise and you feel them,
yeah, you're going to feel
them, but they will pass.
You don't have to follow them anymore
down the rabbit hole.
Just remember, it's just a thought.
Don't touch it, just stop
and fix your attention
in that silence, nothing
more, very simpmle.
You don't have to fight control
or defeat the mind, just stay as you are.
How simple is that?
Just stay as you are as the silence
in between two thoughts and the mind will
dissolve by itself into the
nothingness that it really is.
Hey, yo, whatever it is
that you're going through,
I want to tell you that
you are exactly where
you need to be.
You see this?
This is a lotus flower.
Some say it is the most
beautiful fragrant flowre
on the face of the earth,
but the funny thing is, it
was born out of the nasty
dirty, ugly swamp.
The swamp, the mud.
You don't grow lotuses on
marble or in the highlands,
only from the mud can this
beautiful flower emerge.
I want to tell you that you are the lotus.
All of the ugly situations, your past,
the struggle, the strife is necessary.
You need these situations to force
you to become what you were destined to be
which is greatness.
So hold your ground.
Keep moving forward out of that mud.
I promise you that you will get through
and all of that ugliness, the struggle,
the strife will make your victory speech
that much more beautiful.
Peace.